[Music]
in dangerous concert news Oh submitted
by Denny Chin a suicide bomber attacks
in Manchester killing 22 people at an
ariana grande - [ __ ] damn man why they
do that oh this one was a suicide bomber
mm-hmm yeah so many questions about this
like who did it what was the purpose
what area exactly and why why Ariana
Grande Conte yeah that's my thing it's
like you're trying to target little
girls
they're like little teens yeah it seems
like they were trying to target children
oh my god
yeah so out of the 22 people majority of
them were kids
yeah and if it wasn't that it was like
parents waiting to pick up their kids
from the concert because it happened
after her performance everyone was
starting to leave and that's when it's
22 year olds name Stallman
Betty he had like a backpack on and he
ended up donating a bomb killing 22
people don't they got like metal
detectors and [ __ ] at these concerts was
it outside because you said people are
getting picked up yeah so this is the
bomber he was like a bootleg Drake
that's not too many times it also looks
like mclovin oh yeah Disney's glasses
here is a map of the entire scene so
right here is in Manchester Arena that's
where the concert happened so right here
is a Victoria Station which is the
second largest train station right here
was the box office so there was this
foyer where you leaving the arena
heading towards the train station this
is where he detonated the bomb he mapped
it out nothing like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
man that's crazy that he did the
research because I'm pretty sure when
they had their meeting
like one guy like we shouldn't attack
the UK move deal and I don't think so I
think we should do this actually showing
my demographic research ariana grande
has exactly two demographic oh I like to
kill who is already under the ground
they are another conviction is beautiful
music
she's the Nickelodeon Disney star one of
those not a Starbucks coffee drinkers
nothing No
a beautiful young lady with a lot of
team demographic we should do it pull
votes Mae Mae was a gay vote it and they
actually knew where she was that's crazy
yeah so this bomber he was from
Manchester so he's born in the UK I was
at the long active cocked up side so
recently he went to Libya so his parents
fled Libya back you know from Gaddafi's
regime and they fled but then when sea
diving they ended up going back to Libya
and so recently he went to go visit his
family out there and he spent about a
month there and he returned to
Manchester five days before the bombing
so in that time they're saying that he
was [ __ ] brainwashed so years ago
there were people that had called the
terrorism hotline reporting this this
kid oh they knew that he was in Tucson
for the father's a terrorist hotline
gang that if they got like terrorists
help units on standby
Paris hotline this is Shelly speaking
something to be the problem
my lady back understand I'm not sure so
thank you skid that's blowing up the
blade goes in the driveway
I'm kind of worried about him okay well
what's this color the skin what are you
blowing up exact up I am and you have a
pet camel little bit of on the list okay
that's great I didn't know there's a
hotline it's kind of like suicide
hotline or drug abuse hotline or
gamblers anonymous hotline
I know in there honey we go blow the
base glad picture like you know like
those late-night phone sex operator like
you know like in terrace in the
neighborhood it's all 100 blow [ __ ] up
you know that's what she could I could
call a hot night oh yeah he was already
on the radar but for some reason you
know the official said like he's not
that much of a threat there's probably
thousands of millions of people on alena
up so his sister is telling the media
outlets that he was motivated by revenge
foreign Justices towards
Muslims recently so that's why he got
like really extreme and he wanted to you
know get revenge for all this like
wrongdoing that's happening to the
Muslims in the world and that's helped
you did I get two quarters out to do
with ariana grande so he lived near the
arena so I think that's why he ended up
targeting back so he their returns okay
he was lazy Department blow [ __ ] up mama
take three steps or maybe he wanted
somewhere where there's a lot of people
and you saw that that that area has a
lot of people or something look yeah
well his motivation wasn't for the
motivation that most people think it was
out of anger because his people are
being what was discriminated against
which is kind of dumb because it doesn't
help oh nothing for me saying like oh
there's a stereotype that you know
Asians are criminals so you know what
i'ma show them by stealing all their
cars I'm so I could do nothing as to why
it doesn't make any sense you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah so the sister said that quote I
think he saw children Muslim children
dying everywhere in wanted revenge
he saw the explosives America dropped on
children in Syria and he wanted revenge
whether he thought that is between him
and God and so they're also saying that
one of his friends had died last year
after being hit by a car and stabbed
which this pain was a possible sacrum so
that all like fuels his anger we got
pushed to his limit and this is the only
way he can let it off somehow didn't
know what else to do and you want to
give payback I guess yeah that's [ __ ]
sad image of that night and that's so
sad all these innocent people get a
heart it's like a domino effect of anger
right now the time they ended up getting
leaked images of evidence that they
found so this is the detonator that
they're saying that was found in his
left hand which ones whole body got
blown up except for his left hand I'm
not sure maybe who teaches actually like
the movies yes you know like in the
movie they have a detonator there it's
always like see like that and how do you
hooked up with that stuff I don't know
what does that append like
ballpoint pen color saying that Isis has
been uploading videos recently as like
how to make bombs at home - yeah I don't
know now I just weird images like hi my
name is Azam this I'm today I'm going to
be doing how cats on how to make a bomb
night music oh yeah with a white screen
in the back you got the [ __ ] ring
light so you can see the ring again from
the top I haven't seen the ISIS DIY
videos but what I have seen is the
motivational come join us videos on the
recruitment video and what would you say
to these people are being easily
influenced if you ever want to change
the world change it from the inside it's
going to be harder to do this but let's
say you don't like something that's
happening in government make it a life
choice to [ __ ] be a part of the
government and then you can change it
from the inside it's just easier now for
a lot of people to go I'm mad right now
so I'm just going to go and [ __ ] blow
some [ __ ] up I'm going to beat some
people up but just let that anger turn
into positivity by making it a life
decision could change it from the inside
and and change the situation for you and
other people that's why I say yeah this
really didn't change anything it just
just perpetuated you know stereotypes
yeah and it like raised more red flags
for a particular ethnic group and it
just made things worse I think he didn't
make any sort of impact if anything I
guess he himself like in the afterlife
if you even believe in that
he's probably content but now he's like
bug I'm out here now all my friends and
family they're all like one of them
[ __ ] bootleg Drake and one comma [ __ ]
I'm in heaven on how are we gonna do
that
so these photos of evidence got leaked
to new york times until they published
it and so the mayor of Manchester is
really upset because they compromised
their investigation because you know
there's a lot of key details in here
how's that so this is a 12-volt battery
that was going for the bomb and then
this is a piece of the backpack so he
was wearing do they take all these
pictures in like a contemporary home
that's a good marble countertop and how
easy was it for you to find that
we're on you to the ISIS darling it was
on YouTube in our government dopant
locking they can't just like stop it
because there's nothing that violates
YouTube's Terms for the ones that I saw
oh yeah we got freedom us nobody keep
saying like you know the government
should if you don't want more people
again so there's also freedom of speech
out so it doesn't violate any Buckelew I
mean if that's what they say right but
there I mean you try to speak out of it
or it could have been like taking down
now like I don't know I don't know if
you if I if I watched it during a time
when someone just uploaded it but pretty
much speech doesn't work that if you're
speaking against our government no no
there might be value to speak like that
yeah it's just hate speech that's not
allowed on YouTube oh I thought you
can't do that like if you're like if
there's hate speech that's different
there was also photos of bulbs and mimic
rooms that were used and I keep seeing
and I could thank you judge and then so
ariana grande tweeted out broken from
the bottom of my heart I'm so so sorry I
don't have words so she feels
responsible for what happened she
counseled her towards ooh yeah because
just I was popular
yes that's so crazy and it wasn't even
in her concert it was outside and
walking from her concert to the train
station it just so happened to be after
the concert where majority of her fans
got it I mean yeah it just so happens I
I feel like just for her it's like that
guilty conscious of I want to hold
anymore concerts because I don't want to
lead other people to like assessment
this was a scary world don't cancel your
concerts because you're letting the
terrorists win she might not be in the
right mindset to see yeah did the
plumber has earplugs on could i I was
listening to Ariana Grande's music I
always have so much love I'd like I'm
gonna put this detonator down I wonder
it whenever they are abrading that they
did find evidence that there was I know
that there was a signed poster that can
be remotely detonated if he changed his
mind
there was another guy maybe he did he is
right he's part of a really huge network
that police are saying that this bomb
that was made so what's going back on
what I was saying earlier that Isis has
videos on how to make bombs in your own
home they're saying that this bomb was
not anything like that
made by a professional like Jeremy what
he was doing you should start arresting
everyone I look like a bootlegger it
okay there's probably the bootleg Drake
Association I wear excuse argument that
his brother was also planning a bombing
because when they he probably has bushy
eyebrows too when they raided his home
just suicide bombers home they found
evidence that they could do a lot more
damage so luckily they found all of that
so dad should probably take down the
[ __ ] how to cite how could they just
can't like negotiate you know I mean
like and I get terms like this kid like
if it walks and like hey we need you to
put this bomb on your back and you know
office okay listen how about know how
you do it he already wanted to he wanted
revenge he was general I could get
revenge to while I still live but why
why why do I after that I think they're
so angry that they want to do something
like go out with a bang mmm-hmm hope you
guys enjoyed that episode if you guys
have any juicy little gusts of details
and you guys wanna submit it well guess
what you can cruise on over to the
description box below click on the link
submit the story and hopefully we will
pick it and talk about it for more
videos click right over here
[Music]